8:00 P.M.
SEAN HANNITY TAKES OVER NOW.
>> THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
FOX NEWS ALERT.
MASSIVE AND GREAT NEWS.
THE DOW JONES INDUSTRIAL AVERAGE
JUMPED A WHOPPING 1,290 POINTS
AND AS THE DOW, S&P, AND THE
NASDAQ ALSO RECORD HIGH, HIGHEST
SINGLE DAY POINT GAINS IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
AFTER A WEEK OF CORONA RELATED
PANIC, LIES, PROPAGANDA,
MISINFORMATION, THANKFULLY THE
MARKET IS ROARING BACK IN A BIG
WAY.
WE HAVE A FULL REPORT COMING UP
ON THE PROGRAM TONIGHT BUT FIRST
IN 246 DAYS, IT’S GOING TO GO
LIKE THAT, YOU ARE THE ULTIMATE
JURY.
YOU WILL HAVE A CHANCE TO ONCE
AGAIN SHOCK THE WORLD AND SEND
PRESIDENT TRUMP BACK TO THE
WHITE HOUSE FOR FOUR MORE YEARS.
BUT IT NEEDS TO BE VERY CLEAR TO
EVERY AMERICAN AND WE WILL TRY
TO MAKE IT CLEAR EVERY NIGHT ON
THIS PROGRAM AND THE DEMOCRATS,
THE MEDIA MOB, THEY WILL STOP AT
NOTHING.
THEY WILL DO ANYTHING.
AND I MEAN ANYTHING, TO STOP
DONALD TRUMP.
THEIR RAGE, HATE TRUMPED
PSYCHOSIS IS EVEN FAR WORSE THAN
I THOUGHT, THE LEVEL OF
DERANGEMENT IS OFF THE CHARTS
AND NOW TONIGHT ESPECIALLY I
WANT YOU TO PAY VERY CLOSE
ATTENTION AS WE PROVE OUR POINT
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOW USING THE
NATURAL FEAR OF A VIRUS AS A
POLITICAL WEAPON.
WE HAVE ALL THE EVIDENCE TO
PROVE IT.
AS SHE WILL POLITICIZING,
WEAPONIZING OF YES, THE
CORONAVIRUS.
REMEMBER FIRST RUSSIA, RUSSIA,
RUSSIA.
PEACH, IMPEACH, IMPEACH.
OBSTRUCTION, OBSTRUCTION,
WHATEVER.
NOW THE DEMOCRATS THE MEDIA MOB
ARE SMEARING THE PRESIDENT AND
HIS ADMINISTRATION OF THE SPREAD
OF THE CORONAVIRUS AND BEYOND
EGREGIOUS WAYS.
THE DOUBLE STANDARD AND
DEMOCRACY OF THE MOB AND THE
DEMOCRATS HAS NEVER BEEN WORSE.
SO TONIGHT WE ASK YOU TO PAY
VERY CLOSE ATTENTION AS WE PROVE
THIS POINT TO YOU.
THE INFORMATION WE ARE GIVING
YOU IS NOT INFORMATION YOU’RE
GOING TO FIND ANYWHERE ELSE, AND
IT WILL EXPOSE YET AGAIN THE
ABSOLUTE CORRUPTION, DISHONESTY,
FRAUD AND THE POLITICAL AGENDA
OF DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA MOB,
THEIR STATE RUN TV.
WE START WITH SMEAR NUMBER ONE.
FOR DAYS, THE LEFT HAS BEEN
CLAIMING THE PRESIDENT IS NOT
PREPARED TO HANDLE THE DISEASE
EFFECTIVELY.
WELL, AS A MATTER OF FACT,
BIDEN, BLOOMBERG, THE ENTIRE MOB
AND THE MEDIA, OTHERS HAD
PRESIDENT TRUMP UP THE FUNDING
TO NIH AND CDC.
THAT’S 100% FALSE.
THE EXACT OPPOSITE HAPPENED.
FUNNY ACTUALLY WENT UP.
IN FACT A RECENT STUDY FROM JOHN
HOPKINS UNIVERSITY RANKED THE
UNITED STATES NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER ONE IN THE WORLD AT
PANDEMIC PREPAREDNESS.
WE ARE BY FAR THE MOST PREPARED.
THE NEXT LIFE OF THE MEDIA MOB
AND DEMOCRATS IS THE CLAIM THE
PRESIDENT DID NOT ACT QUICKLY
ENOUGH.
THAT’S A BALD-FACED LIE.
LET’S LOOK AT THE TRUTH THAT
NOBODY ELSE WILL REPORT, AND WE
HAVE AN ACTUAL TIMELINE AND YOU
CAN FOLLOW ALONG AT HOME.
IT’S LIKE FOLLOW THE BOUNCING
BALL.
THIS OFFICIALLY STARTED BELIEVE
IT OR NOT ON DECEMBER 30, 2019.
NOT THAT LONG AGO.
WE HAD A CLUSTER OF PATIENTS
WITH PNEUMONIA AND AN UNKNOWN
PROVENANCEPROVINCE OBSERVED IN W
CHINA.
THAT WAS REPORTED TO THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION.
IT WASN’T UNTIL JANUARY 7 THAT
THE VIRUS, THE CORONAVIRUS, WAS
ACTUALLY IDENTIFIED AND ISOLATED
IN THESE PATIENTS.
THREE WEEKS LATER, ON JANUARY 31
OF THIS YEAR, THE PRESIDENT
DECLARED A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY.
THAT MEANT AMERICANS RETURNING
FROM AREAS MOST IMPACTED, THEY
WERE SUBJECT TO MANDATORY
QUARANTINE, TWO WEEKS OF
MILITARY BASES.
THAT’S WHEN THE TRAVEL BAN
BEGAN.
TWO DAYS LATER, TEMPORARY TRAVEL
BAN WENT INTO EFFECT FOR ALL
NON-U.S. CITIZENS WHO RECENTLY
VISITED CHINA AND MY SOURCES
WERE ACTUALLY IN THE ROOM WITH
THE PRESIDENT MADE THIS DECISION
ON JANUARY 31, SAID THERE ARE
ABOUT 25 PEOPLE IN THE ROOM, NO
ONE AGREED WITH THE PRESIDENT TO
IMPLEMENT THE TRAVEL BAN, SO
THAT THERE WOULD BE POLITICAL
CONSEQUENCES IF HE DID BUT HE
DID IT ANYWAY.
AND HE DID IT IN RECORD TIME.
EVERYONE ELSE SAID MAYBE IT’S
TOO EARLY.
HE MADE THE CALL.
MY SOURCES CONFIRM TO ME TONIGHT
YOU CAN STOP RIGHT THERE.
THIS ONE EARLY BOLD DECISION OF
THIS PRESIDENT LIKELY PREVENTED
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS FROM CONTRACTING THIS
VIRUS.
HAS ANYONE IN THE MEDIA MOB WILL
DO THAT?
IT WASN’T UNTIL FEBRUARY 11TH
BUT THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION OFFICIALLY NAMED
THE VIRUS.
THE PRESIDENT WAS WAY AHEAD OF
THEM.
A TASK FORCE LED BY TRUMP’S
NUMBER TWO,
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE, IS
UNDERWAY.
IT’S FILLED WITH AMERICA’S TOP
SCIENTISTS.
SO FAR, THANKFULLY LESS THAN TEN
PEOPLE IN THE COUNTRY HAVE DIED
FROM THIS VIRUS.
NOW WE NEED TO PUT THAT IN
PERSPECTIVE.
LET US COMPARE THIS TO H1 AND,
SWINE FLU VIRUS.
AS IT’S KNOWN.
IT HIT THE U.S. IN APRIL OF
2009.
IT WASN’T UNTIL SIX MONTHS LATER
IN OCTOBER OF 2009, AFTER MORE
THAN 20,000 AMERICANS WERE
HOSPITALIZED, MORE THAN 1,000 OF
OUR FELLOW CITIZENS DIED.
ONLY THEN DID PRESIDENT OBAMA
AND YEAH, QUID PRO QUO JOE
DECLARE A NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
AFTER 20,000 OF OUR FELLOW
CITIZENS HOSPITALIZED, MORE THAN
1,000 AMERICANS.
NOW DO YOU REMEMBER AT THAT TIME
ANYBODY IN THE MEDIA STIRRING UP
THESE TYPE OF HYSTERIA AS THEY
ARE DOING NOW?
DO YOU REMEMBER THE END OF DAYS
PREDICTIONS?
DID THE STOCK MARKET TAKE
BECAUSE OF ALL THE RECKLESS
LYING AND FEARMONGERING?
THAT DID NOT HAPPEN IN 2009.
IN FACT, THE MARKET WENT UP, AS
SWINE FLU CASES MOUNTED.
PRETTY INTERESTING.
A TALE OF TWO PRESIDENTS.
ON THE ONE SIDE, OBAMA-BIDEN,
THEY GET THE WHITE GLOVE
TREATMENT FROM THEIR WILLING
ACCOMPLICES AND FELLOW RADICAL
STREAM SOCIALIST THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
ON THE OTHER SIDE, THE MOB IN
THREE WEEKS BLUDGEONED
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WEAPONIZING
THIS VIRUS, TO DESTROY HIM
POLITICALLY.
ONE PERSON AT YAHOO! NEWS EVEN
SUGGESTING THIS COULD BE TRUMP’S
KATRINA.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" ALSO
OPENLY WONDERING IF YOU WOULD
BECOME TRUMPS KATRINA.
"NEW YORK TIMES" HACK PAUL
KRUGMAN ACTUALLY CHEERED.
HOW DO YOU CHEER WHEN WE ARE
LOSING MONEY WHEN THE STOCK
MARKET FELL?
25,000.
"NEW YORK TIMES" EDITORIAL.
"NEW YORK TIMES" SAID THIS IS
THE TERM VIRUS, WRITING "IF
YOU’RE FEELING AWFUL, YOU KNOW
WHO TO BLAME."
BY THE WAY, AS PRESIDENT TRUMP
WAS LITERALLY REACTING IN RECORD
TIME, WHAT WERE THE DEMOCRATS
DOING TO REPAIR THIS COUNTRY FOR
THE PANDEMIC AT THE END
OF JANUARY AND EARLY FEBRUARY?
OH, THEY COULDN’T BE BOTHERED.
WHY QUESTION RIGHT THEY WERE
CONSUMED WITH THEIR IMPEACHMENT
CONSPIRACY THEORIES HOAX AND
WITCH HUNT.
THE FINAL VOTE DIDN’T TAKE PLACE
ON IMPEACHMENT TILL FEBRUARY 12,
NEARLY TWO WEEKS AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP ACTED DECISIVELY
WITH AN AGGRESSIVE PLAN FRANKLY
UNPRECEDENTED TO STOP THE SPREAD
OF THE CORONAVIRUS WHEN
HE HAD HIS TRAVEL BAN PUT IN
PLACE.
HE DID ALL THIS WHILE HE WAS
BEING IMPEACHED.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT PUT IN PLACE
TRAVEL BAN, AT THAT TIME, THAT
GUY, QUID PRO QUO JOE CALLED THE
PRESIDENT’S TRAVEL BAN AND
QUARANTINE EFFORTS "PART OF A
RECORD OF XENOPHOBIA AND
FEARMONGERING."
SO MANY MORE THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE.
HOW MANY MORE WOULD’VE
CONTRACTED THE VIRUS?
WE DIDN’T QUARANTINE PEOPLE THAT
CAME IN FROM CHINA, OR CITIZENS,
FOR TWO WEEKS AND WE DIDN’T HAVE
A TRAVEL BAN.
SORRY.
YOU’RE PART OF THE WORLD SICK.
YOU CAN’T GET IN.
HE DID THAT THREE WEEKS.
BIDEN, OBAMA, THEY WAITED SIX
MONTHS IN 1,000 PEOPLE DIED.
IN 2009 AND ’10.
FAKE NEWS CNN, WHERE THEY SING
AT THE TIME WITH THE TRAVEL BAN?
WELL, THEY WERE PROMOTING THE
POTENTIAL STIGMA AND FEAR THAT
THE TRAVEL BAN WOULD CAUSE.
AND FAKE NEWS CNN WOULD’VE ALSO
BEEN RESPONSIBLE IF, IN FACT,
THE VAN WASN’T IN PLACE AND
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
OUR FELLOW AMERICANS CONTRACTED
THIS DISEASE.
THEY WOULD BE CRITICAL OF TRUMP
FOR DOING THAT.
NOW THE DEMOCRATS AND THE MOB,
THEY ARE JUST OUTRIGHT LYING.
NBC NEWS, FAKE NEWS CNN, MS DNC,
OTHERS, SHARE, HOLLYWOOD,
ACTUALLY CLAIMING THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS CALLING THE
CORONAVIRUS A HOAX.
NO, THAT’S ANOTHER COMPLETE LIE.
INSTEAD THE PRESIDENT CALLED THE
WEAPONIZATION AND POLITICIZING
OF THE VIRUS A HOAX.
WE HAVE THE TAPE TO PROVE IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> President Trump: NOW THE
DEMOCRATS ARE POLITICIZING THE
CORONAVIRUS.
YOU KNOW THAT, RIGHT?
THEY ARE POLITICIZING IT.
WE DID ONE OF THE GREAT JOBS.
YOU SAY HOW WAS RESIDENT FROM
DOING?
THEY GO BOW, NOT GOOD.
NOT GOOD.
ONE OF MY PEOPLE CAME AT ME AND
SAID MR. PRESIDENT, THEY TRIED
TO BEAT YOU ON RUSSIA RUSSIA
RUSSIA.
THAT DIDN’T WORK OUT TOO WELL.
THEY COULDN’T DO IT.
THEY TRIED THE IMPEACHMENT HOAX.
THEY TRIED IT OVER AND OVER.
THEY’VE BEEN DOING IT SINCE YOU
GOT IN.
IT’S ALL TURNING.
THEY LOST.
INK OF IT.
THINK OF IT.
AND THIS IS THEIR NEW HOAX.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT AND
CALL THE VIRUS A HOAX.
NO, HE PUT IN PLACE QUARANTINE
STUDY PUT IN PLACE TRAVEL BAN’S
BUT THE MOB AND THE MEDIA, WHY
WOULD THEY EVER LET FACTS GET IN
THE WAY OF GOOD ANTI-TRUMP SMEAR
WHICH IS ALL THEY’VE BEEN DOING
FOR THREE YEARS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> JUST TONIGHT AT A RALLY, HE
WENT A STEP FURTHER AND CALLED
THE CORONAVIRUS A HOAX.
>> THIS IS THE SAME PRESIDENT
WHO REFERRED TO THE CORONAVIRUS
AS A HOAX.
>> HOW DID THEY ANSWER THAT A
GUY LIKE SENATOR SANDERS IS MORE
CAPABLE THAN DONALD TRUMP?
WHO HAS CALLED THE CORONAVIRUS A
HOAX.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP LATE INTO THE
DEMOCRATS WERE RAISING ALARM,
CALLING IT A HOAX.
>> THE IDEA THAT DONALD TRUMP
SAID JUST SEVERAL DAYS AGO THIS
WAS A DEMOCRATIC HOAX, WHAT IN
GODS NAME IS HE TALKING ABOUT?
TO GO I FIND IT INCOMPREHENSIBLE
THAT THE PRESIDENT WOULD DO
SOMETHING AS INANE AND CALLING
IT A HOAX WHICH HE DID LAST
NIGHT IN SOUTH CAROLINA.
>> HE SAID THAT THE DEMOCRATS
MAKING SO MUCH IF IT IS A
DEMOCRATIC HOAX, NOT FOR THE
VIRUS WAS A HOAX.
>> Sean: THEY ARE ALL LYING
YET AGAIN BECAUSE OF A POLITICAL
AGENDA.
HATE TRUMP AGENDA.
BUT NOT A WORD, NOT A PEEP INTO
THOUSAND NINE END ’10.
20,000 OF OUR FELLOW AMERICANS
CONTRACTING SWINE FLU, SIX
MONTHS, WHAT DID BIDEN-OBAMA DO?
NOTHING.
1,000 DEAD AMERICANS.
OH, NOW WE WILL DECLARE A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
THAT’S HOW CORRUPT AND MORALLY
BANKRUPT YOUR MEDIA MOB HAS
BECOME IN YOUR DEMOCRATIC PARTY
IS.
THEN YOU’VE GOT LATE NIGHT
LIBERAL BILL MAHER.
WELL, HE MIGHT TAKE THE CAKE.
OVER THE WEEKEND HE ACTUALLY
CLAIMED THAT THE PRESIDENT WOULD
LIKE TO USE THE VIRUS TO DECLARE
MARTIAL LAW.
THIS IS THE SAME GUY BY THE WAY
THAT WANTED OH, A RECESSION.
BECAUSE IT WOULD HELP THE
DEMOCRATS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SINCE TRUMP, I THINK IS NOT
GOING TO LEAVE ANYWAY, MIGHT AS
WELL RUN BERNIE.
HE’S NOT.
AND BY THE WAY, WITH THE VIRUS
GETS BAD HE’S GOING TO DECLARE
MARTIAL LAW.
WATCH THAT.
THAT COULD TOTALLY HAPPEN.
>> Sean: LIES, CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, SMEAR SLANDER TO OPUS
PARCHMENT FROM THE MEDIA UNLIKE
ANYTHING WE’VE EVER EXPERIENCED.
A RAW, NAKED POLITICAL AGENDA
THAT THEY HATE THE PRESIDENT BUT
THEY ALSO THOSE OF A SMELLY
WALMART TRUMP SUPPORTER IS
BELIEVE IN GOD, GUNS, BIBLE, YOU
KNOW CONSTITUTION.
THEY ARE NOT LOOKING OUT FOR
YOUR SAFETY, YOUR SECURITY OR
WELL-BEING.
THE ONE THING THEY CARE ABOUT
AND THE ONLY THING IS PLACATING
THE PSYCHOTIC RAGE AND HYPOCRISY
AND DOUBLE STANDARD BECAUSE THEY
HATE DONALD TRUMP.
THAT’S WHY THIS ELECTION MEANS
SOMETHING.